everyone's here we go you got into two
things for stations but number one
you're going to find them and then you
also to determine their nature right so
in terms of stationary points sometimes
these to get phrase in a different way
they'll say find turning points okay can
you see that finding turning points
really amounts to doing these two things
you've got to find the station first
then you've got to determine the nature
of the station points and then I'll tell
you against max where it's a min or it's
neither okay so how do we find it okay
what do we do station quits what's the
first thing we have to do a stationary
point is defined by it's got a um a
horizontal tangent okay so the gradient
that point is zero so what you're gonna
do is solve the one DX is equal to zero
okay you solve that you're gonna find it
but secondly if you want to actually
find where the location of points is
when you guys are ready
Joanne asks question still ready I'm
still waiting still waiting okay
so this will tell you the x-coordinates
where you got a stationary point then
you're going to do a little more legwork
than that you've got actually pop it
back into your original equation okay
and that'll give you the whiteboard so
sub back into Y and that will give you
the whiteboard okay so there's two steps
then you found them okay but if they're
asking you to find turning points or if
they ask you to determine the nature of
those station reports which are really
the same thing you've got to go a little
further
okay now by this point because we know
the first and second rib are right we
now have two different ways to different
methods for determining the nature of
station point okay so method one okay
what do you do you want to test the
first derivative on either side okay
testing one in the X just to the left
and just to the right okay now when you
test you want to pick values that number
one are nice and easy for you and number
two don't go too far plus other
stationary points okay so you want to
select values carefully you know for
instance if you found a stationary point
at x equals one okay so you go to the
left on the right excuse me you could
just go just a little bit to the left
you know 0.9 and just a little bit to
the right one point one and then
probably give you some helpful values
but 0.9 1.1 a difficult fiddly numbers
to work with so we probably want to pick
numbers like say 0 1 2 so those are easy
values right but in the same way for
instance suppose I found a stationary
point at 1 and a stationary point - well
then I can't pick 2 as a value to test
on the right I'd have to pick something
in between like say one and a half okay
so sometimes you can't get away from
picking
an annoying number because you have to
be between stationary points okay so
select your values carefully then once
you've tested it you'll have one of
three conclusions okay number one
give me a local max okay because you go
up then across and then down down she
could be a local minimum okay if you get
the reverse or what was the third
alternative especially important what
else could you have yeah if you have a
plenty reflection at the same time right
you're gonna get a horizontal point on
inflection she's neither a minimum nor a
maximum so you can get this to wait you
can get up across up that's a horizontal
point inflection or you could get down
across yeah also I got to a point
function okay so when you test on either
side the first three people will tell
you any of these okay so that's a method
one
what was that second way would you
remember this is the new way right yeah
that's right use concavity so find out
let's plug it down or concave up so if
you want to do is rather than test the
first derivative on either side you test
the second derivative at that point okay
okay so at the stationary point as
opposed to on either side yeah all right
so therefore you're going to get some
conclusions from that right depending on
the value of the second derivative if
the second derivative is negative okay
like so what does that tell you negative
second derivative that means it's
concave down okay so that's poking down
which tells you it's which kind of a
point that's a that's a match right okay
so there's the first option if you got a
positive second derivative obviously
everything is backwards so you're
concave up and you have a minimum and
then here's what you gonna be careful
yeah if your second derivative I just
ran out of space here so I'm just gonna
keep going if you're sicker in
derivative is zero okay what could that
mean now remember we looked at counter
examples here she can't be dogmatic
right what it means is you have a
possible point of inflection
okay now if its first two to zero second
root is zero remember it could be X to
the four way X to the six so it may not
be an actual horizontal point inflection
so in this way you can see when you
contrast the two methods right testing
the first review tends to be a bit
bolder Boris because you've got a test
values and so on okay but it's more
reliable because when you've got the
values on either side you know for sure
it's a horizontal plane reflection or a
max review okay
here you're like well maybe okay so if
this is what you got you got first three
zero second derivative zero what would
you do next how could you tell what it
was you could go to the third derivative
I'm gonna try and avoid that because you
can end up with similar problems right
what I would do is you either resort
back to this test you go back to testing
the first rivet on either side and
that'll tell you is going down across
down horizontal point flexion or the
reverse or if you want to verify that it
is a point inflection and this is
getting to the next kind of critical
point how do I verify that something's
playing flexure what is the point
inflection me is a change in concavity
right so I would then have to test the
second derivative on either side okay
see ya yeah so you can see when you get
the second news being zero
okay you've got to be careful so you
can't just say ah it looks like this so
I reckon if they say prove that it's one
or the other you must test you've got a
second
you got he's the first one go do
something okay so this is stationary
points remember you got two different
methods generally we like the second
derivative okay because it tends to be
faster but you were avoided if your
fraction is rational sorry if your
function is rational do you remember why
why do you want to avoid the second
review
if you've got a rational function yeah
that's right if you have something like
say this okay you differentiate once
because using the quotient rule you're
gonna end up with another fraction but
worse and then if you differentiate
again to the second derivative it just
keeps on getting worse and worse and
worse not only does it get worse your
method is more error-prone because it's
more complicated case you're more likely
to get a bad result okay all right the
stationary points